pleasure for me to be here i at stanford
and give this talk in person
and so as you know i'm an assistant
professor at usc where i direct the
ikaros lab interactive and collaborative
collaborative autonomous robotic systems
lab
and when i started at usc i wanted to
find an application of the robots that
we have in the lab that actually is
useful and has an impact on people and
so i went to a facility with a post rock
patient
and i asked them if you have a robotic
arm like this one that we have in the
lab
what would you like the arm to do and
people said things like i would like the
arm to help me eat meal preparation but
what they really made an impression on
me was a lady that and she told me that
she would like this robotic arm to help
her comb her hair
and that's a that's an interesting
application because it's not something
that you need
for survival but it has an important
self-image and
self-image aspect and so i said okay
what can we do to make this system
a share coming system and so we
implemented a system with a kinect they
connect
[Music]
detects a person's hair builds a mesh
adapted to a given hairstyle and then we
use that mesh to plan a path to plan a
constraint path with a robot arm
and
comb the person's hair
and so we can this way we can like fly
of different copying strategies for
different hair styles
and then i said okay we have the system
in the lab and it worked very robustly
what do we need to do to actually move
that system from the lab to the real
world
and
in a sense in order to do that we should
be able to account for the different
undesirable behaviors that may occur so
for example what happens if the user
raises their arms well for that case
what we did is we built them
a skin conductance sensor on the comp so
that as soon as it gets in touch with
the skin the robot will stop as a safety
mechanism
but there are many many desirable
behaviors and many many different things
that can go wrong that we should account
for if we want to deploy this system for
for a large amount of time like with
real users
and so our thesis is that robust human
robot interaction requires identifying
and accounting for different undesirable
behaviors
and one way to do that would be through
user studies and i've spent my entire
career doing user studies but there is a
limited number of
user behaviors and environments that you
can cover in the user study
and so instead especially as the systems
become more and more complex and less
and less transparent you want to
somehow be able to systematically test
these systems and so the question that
we are going to ask is can we
automatically generate scenarios that
test uh and find failure cases for
complex hri systems
and so as an example application we you
we will use the shared autonomy via
hindsight optimization
uh system and in that system the robot
uses the robot runs a partially
observable markov decision process a
pamdp
uses the user inputs through a joystick
interface as observations infers what
the user's goal is among a guided date
set of different goals and then assists
the user for that goal
so that's the third autonomy system
that's a system that we will try to find
failure scenarios so a success case of
that system is shown here where there
are two goal objects the user wants to
go to the left object the t it points to
the left with a joystick the system uses
a joystick input says observations
infers that the user wants to go to the
black tea and helps the user give that
code and this is a very robust system so
we actually went to kinova robotics
so we had this system during my phd
studies we went to kinova robotics and
we tested with axial spinal cord injury
patients and it worked very very
robustly for a number of users and i
said okay can we generate scenarios in
simulation that result in system
failures
now what is a scenario inside autonomy a
scenario in that case would be
moving objects around but also
simulating user inputs
and so we will try in simulation to find
different human input sequences and also
different object locations that result
in failures
now one of one approach would be to
formulate that is a single objective
optimization problem where you try to
find a global optimum where the global
optimum minimizes
the third autonomy system's performance
but this the scenario that you would
come up if you try to do that would be a
scenario where the user is maximally
adversarial or deceptive
and these scenarios that that are global
optima are pretty easy to find and they
are not very interesting
instead what we would like to have is we
want to have a diverse range of
challenging scenarios scenarios where
the user is optimal but also scenarios
where the user is noisy scenarios where
the scene is cluttered but also
scenarios where the scene is where the
objects in the scene are spread out
and when we were trying to actually
search for a diverse range of high
quality solutions we found out that
there is actually an entire community or
sub-community that focuses on this
problem on finding diverse solutions and
that's a quality diversity problem
and so in single objective optimization
you typically have one objective when
you try to find a global optimum in
multi-objective optimization you have
two or more objectives and you search
for a pareto front
diversity driven search does not care
about objectives but tries to fill in a
space specified by measure functions so
it tries to find a solution for every
output combination of the two or more
measure functions
quality diversity has an objective that
wants to maximize but also it has one or
more measure functions which are the
measures of diversity
and form a space that you want to fill
in
and so formally we assume an objective
and some measures and this form a
measure space and the quality diversity
objective is to for every output
combination of the measure functions
find the solution and that quality of
that solution be maximized and so we
want to find a collection of solutions
that fill in the measure space that are
as high quality as possible
now to solve that problem you would need
infinite memory because the measure
space is continuous and so what
state-of-the-art quality diversity
algorithms do is they use an approximate
objective where the space is tessellated
so essentially what they do is we
partition the space to cells and then we
try to fill in as many cells as possible
with solutions of as high quality as
possible
a state-of-the-art quality diversity
algorithm is map elites
the idea behind map elites is you have a
high dimensional search space
these are the scenario parameters and
you map this to a lower dimensional
measure space where the measures are the
measures of diversity that you care
about is the functions that you want to
have an output for every output
combination of these functions
and you want to find solutions that fill
in that space but also the quality is as
high as possible
and the way map elites works is that it
retains an archive of best performers so
it keeps track for every cell what is
the solution that has performed the best
so far and then if it finds a better
solution it discards a previous one and
replaces it with a new solution
also if a new solution
finds an empty cell in the archive it
adds a solution to the archive so it
keeps track of an archive of elites
hence the name of the best performer so
far and so the way it works is at first
you sample some initial solutions from a
fixed distribution and you populate the
archive and then you iteratively select
this elite solutions from the archive
and you perturb them a little bit so you
apply some
perturbation with an isotropic gaussian
and you generate new solutions and the
insight here is that existing solutions
can be used as stepping stones so
existing high performing solutions are
likely with some perturbation to
generate new high performing solutions
in other parts of the archive
so this is how map elites works right it
tries to find an archive of solutions
solutions that are diverse with respect
to some measures of diversity
and we said can we actually apply map
elites to generate scenarios for the
shared autonomy domain
and what we varied the measures of
diversity was distance between objects
so intuitively the more cluttered the
scene the harder for the robot will be
to disambiguate between the two objects
and also we varied the amount of
variation from the optimal path how
noisy the human is and again intuitively
the noisier the user the harder for the
robot it would be to understand what the
user intent is
and we said okay can we generate a
diverse range of scenarios that result
in system failure so the quality the
quality that we want to maximize is is
to minimize performance of the shared
autonomy system right so we want the hr
system to fail
and so this is if you run map elites on
that you get an archive of solutions so
this is a resulting archive where the
x-axis is the amount of variation the
total amount of noise
so variation from the optimal path so as
you go to the right you have a noisier
human the y-axis is distance between two
objects each cell here represents a
scenario and the color represents
performance so red color indicates a
maximum system timeout where the shared
autonomy system was unable to reach the
user's goal
for the
pre-specified time limit so it's a red
red color indicates that the system has
failed right it's a failure scenario
okay so we get an archive of solutions
the first question to ask is how does
map elite work and how does it compare
to uniformly sampling the
the scenario parameters so what if
uniformly example like object locations
and human inputs can we generate diverse
scenarios this way
and we see that map elites generates
more diverse scenarios but also more
failure scenarios
why this is the case
the the reason behind that is a
phenomenon called the measure space
distortion where the idea is the
following if you sample a high
dimensional search base and map this to
a lower dimensional measure space
you get a measure you get the samples to
concentrate on a small region so let me
give you an example if you uniformly
place objects on a table
you get diversity with respect to object
positions but what if you care about the
distances between two objects
the probability that all objects are
maximally distance distant becomes very
very small if you're uniform sample
objects the probability that they are
all very close to each other is very
very small and you can actually saw from
properties of random vectors that the
sample distances are all concentrated on
a very small region
and so even though you get diversity
with respect to objects positions you
don't get diversity with respect to the
lower dimensional metric that you care
about and this happens in many many
domains where you map a high dimensional
scenario space to a lower dimensional
feature space
and this is why map elites works better
than random search in that case because
it takes existing solutions from the
archive perturbs them a little bit and
then uses the existing solutions to
populate the archive as much as possible
it also performs better than covariance
metrics adaptation evolution strategy
cmas which is a state-of-the-art
derivative free optimizer and that's
expected because cmas tries to find a
single global optimum instead of a
diverse range of high quality solutions
okay and we can also like this
quantitative difference that you see we
can also compute a quality diversity
score which is the a metric that
summarizes diversity and quality of
solutions and we can see that they
perform better than all the baselines
but i think what is really interesting
is to see what these failures look like
so if we have this hri system and we try
to find these scenarios and we reproduce
them in the real world how do they look
like why the system fails
so this is a success case where the
system works well
let's try to see a failure cases so a
failure case here this one selected here
is a case where there is large amount of
variation from the optimal path so the
user is very very noisy
well if we reproduce this in the real
world it looks something like that so
the noise here is ejecting motion to the
right and the system gets confused and
thinks that the user wants to go to the
white object instead of the black t and
get stuck there
that's not very surprising if there is
noise in user inputs and the system uses
a user input says observations the
system will get confused what was really
surprising is that we found failure
cases even for a nearly optimal user so
even if the user provides based on some
rationality metric the optimal input
sequence
the system will still fail
if we reproduce this scenario in the
real world we get this object
configuration and what happens is that
the system uses a distance based
observation function
and even though the user optimally
points to the right object to the object
that they want to go which is the black
t
at the back the system still thinks that
the user wants to go to the white object
because it's closer and gets stuck there
and this is an interesting edge case
that when manually testing the system we
were just moving objects around and we
had not observed but it was discovered
by this
quality diversity scenario generation
algorithm
and so the overall insight that we got
from this work is that quality diverse
algorithm cannot perform baselines in
finding diverse failure cases
to test human robot interaction systems
so we sent this work and it was accepted
to rss and we were very happy about it
but reviewers came back with two very
legitimate concerns and one is that
first maple lease still requires a very
large number of iterations so i don't
know if anyone of you has used ever open
rave but we had actually had we had a
hundred open rave instances running in
parallel in a many core machines for
several hours and so there is a high
computational cost to explore the vast
space the vast continuous space of
scenarios
just a quick question so for each point
in the methylates
one of those cells corresponds to many
particular instantiations of the same
measures
so for each each point there is one
specific scenario so it's an
instantiation of the scenario parameters
so that is a specific human trajectory
human input trajectory and
a specific object location
now the second limitation is that these
scenarios are also pretty simple it's
just object locations
and so in the in the next part of the
talk i'm going to address these two
limitations and see how we can improve
the efficiency of searching the scenario
space but also how can we generate more
complex scenes more complex scenarios
how does map elites work so map elites
selects uniformly solutions from the
archive and applies an isotropic
gaussian
an implicit assumption when applying
this
random perturbation is that every
direction is equally promising
that that's what an isotropic noise
means
so can we instead do better can instead
generate solutions in the direction of
maximizing the quality diversity
objective which is to find solutions
that fill in the archive as much as
possible but also solutions that are as
high quality as possible
so instead of applying a noise that is
isotropic and where every direction is
equally likely can we search for a
solution that maximizes archive
improvement that fills in the archive as
fast as possible
so in a sense what we would like to do
is we would like to compute some sort of
a gradient of the quality diversity
objective with respect to the current
archive and move in the direction of
that gradient move in the direction of
sleep as ascent
now what is a gradient a gradient is a
small perturbation
that is in the direction of maximum
improvement
how can we perturb the archive a little
bit
well we do that either by adding a new
solution or by replacing an existing
solution with a new better solution
the key insight is that we search for
that
solution that new solution that
maximizes archive improvement
and we formulate that searches and
optimization problem
and so we can use cmas covariance
metrics adaptation evolution strategy
and what the way cmas works is that we
have a multivariate gaussian with sample
solutions and then we select and rank
them based on some objective metric
and then we update the mean and
covariance matrix of that gaussian
now here what we do is we can use cmas
but instead of selecting and ranking the
solutions on some objective we can
select and run solutions based on how
much the maxim how much they improve the
archive and move in a direction that
maximizes archive improvement
and if we do that then if we combine
these archiving properties of map elites
with a selection and
writing properties of cmas we introduced
a new algorithm called covariance
metrics adaptation map elites
cmame and we were able to show that this
actually performed much much better in
several benchmark domains
and one domain that we'll discuss is the
hearthstone so here zone is a very
interesting game because you select
which move to play but also you select
which cards to have on the deck so it's
like learning how to play chess where
you select the
the strategy but you also select which
pieces to have on board
and we were used cma me to search for
diverse strategies so here we don't
search for scenarios we just search for
player strategies
and so the way to do that is we can
represent the strategies and neural
network that ranks board states and then
we can optimize the neural network
parameters with cmami so we do new
revolution where we search for neural
network parameters with cmamy
and the objective is to win as many
games as possible while the measures are
average hand size so how large the deck
is an average number of turns how long
the game is going to last so we want to
have to find strategies that result in
long games but also short games
strategies that
whether the user the player uses a large
number of cards and a small number of
cards
and if we do that we see that compared
to map elites cmame finds a
much larger number of strategies but
also strategies that perform much better
so lighter color here indicates better
performance
what is really interesting is that the
x-axis here is number of turns which is
how long the game is going to last and
if we see how cma-me populates this
archive
it starts first with strategies that
last very little very short amount of
time and then gradually starts finding
strategies that will last longer and
then optimizes these strategies further
so it's like learning how to play chess
where you first do fools mate but this
can get you that far and then you start
trying to play the longer game and then
gradually became become better at it so
we see that the way we specify these
measures of diversity and the way cma me
tries to cover this archive to
with respect to these measures also
forms a natural curriculum that helps it
find better performing strategies
okay so this part and we can also see
some quantitative metrics that show that
perform much better than the baselines
and but these parts show that map elites
can
that we can actually improve a lot of
the search efficiency of map elites to
achieve good results
the second aspect is can we generate
more complex scenarios
and one approach would be to just add
more objects in the scene
but that will generate complex scenes
but it's not exactly what we want
because we want scenes to be complex but
also realistic
like if we were to in a kitchen
environment we would like to the pot to
be on top of the stove and the fruit
basket on top of the table but not the
fruit basket on top of the stove so we
want some realism in the scenes that we
generate
and so the key insight here is that
instead of searching directly for
environments for object positions we can
search we can train generative models
with human offered examples and then
search use quality diversity to search
the latent space of these generative
models
and in this way we can generate diverse
environments that are also realistic
because they match the style of the
human authored examples that we use to
train these generative models
and so in this example we use the
overcooked game domain so in overcooked
there are two agents that try to perform
a task as quickly as possible
and complete a meal preparation task the
green agent here is like a simulated
robot agent so ransom mdp tries to infer
what the human subtask is and adapt and
help the human for that task
the blue agent is a simulated human so
it runs in some simple rule-based
heuristics
and so these two agents coordinate to
complete the task and the question that
we are asking is can we generate
environments that are diverse with
respect to coordination behaviors
environments that lead to poor
coordination where a lot of agents
remain idle they get stuck and
environments that result in very high
quality coordination
and so what we did is we took the
quality diversity algorithm cma me we
searched the latent space of a gun
and then if we do that and we generate a
level that level will be will match the
style of human authored examples but it
has artifacts
so the output of a gun will match the
training distribution but
you'll see that it has some parts of the
layout here are not easily accessible
there are no pots
and so it's not a playable level it's
not an executable environment
and so what we do is we repair we use
the mixed integer program to repair the
generated environment where we minimize
the number of edits between the input
the gun generated environment and the
output environment
while respecting some playability
constraints
so we can formulate this as a minimum
cost network flow problem where the
objective is to minimize flow
in a spatial graph while satisfying some
constraints for example have a specific
number of objects of each type all parts
being reachable and so on
and then we can simulate agents we can
evaluate
some coordination metrics concurrent
motion age and idle time and do this
iteratively so that we have diverged
environments diverse environments
and if we do that we can see these are
two example environments generated so
the environment on the left side is an
environment where coordination is very
very good so you see all objects are
very easily accessible all agents will
move to the objects that are accessible
and coordinate very well to do the task
the environment on the right on the
other hand
it has a long corridor the two agents
get stuck here
one agent has to wait now this agent has
to wait for the other agent to move on
and so on
it's also very intuitive because you
know you see a long corridor here you
see a crossing
but in the environment generation
process there was nothing that said how
the environment should look like we only
the only measure of diversity was
what is a concurrent motion what is the
percentage of concurrent motion what is
the percentage of the idle time of each
agent and so by generating environments
that are diverse to these measures we
were able to
find environments that are human
intuitive but and also result in diverse
coordination metrics we can also use the
same pipeline to find failures
so if we try to minimize performance you
can see this environment here where
this is a pmdp agent and this is a human
agent and they get stuck and the
rule-based agent based on some heuristic
starts performing random actions
but the result of that is that the pmdp
agent the belief over the human subtask
starts oscillating between two cadillac
tasks and therefore the two agents get
stuck and so this is a corner case based
on the model of the pmdp agent that was
discovered from this environment
generation pipeline
what is really exciting is that we then
removed the simulated human we had
actual human users play the game
and we said though these behaviors that
we observed in simulation translate with
real users
and the answer is yes so
the loading fluency layouts are layouts
that
in simulation had the coordination was
poor
height and fluency are layouts where the
simulation of the coordination was very
high
and you see the percentage of concurrent
motion when we had axial human users in
a user study play the game and we see
that for loading fluency layouts the
percentage of concurrent motion was
significantly smaller
and so we see that the behaviors that we
observed with even a rough human
modeling simulation translated when we
had actually real users
and so when i was playing with
generative adversarial networks i
thought can we actually use the same to
generate video game levels and in fact
before coming to the states and starting
my graduate studies i worked in japan
for a few years at square enix in
procedural content generation and one
thing that i very very quickly found out
was that
video game designers like we spent a lot
of time like optimizing and getting the
content right and video game designers
never use it
but instead they took that content and
for them it was a starting point for
exploration
so designers want to have a diverse
range of high quality content that they
can use to explore and so we ask the
question can we generate diverse video
game levels where we have a gun with
human authored examples and we train the
gun and then we have a mario like these
are mario scenes play the level like an
ai agent running an a-star algorithm
and then but then instead of just
sampling from the training distribution
of the gun can we say can we instead
search for levels that are diverse with
respect to the number of enemies
and number of sky tiles so some features
of diversity that we care about
and so this is an example level
resulting that this has a large number
of enemies and a small number of sky
tiles
this is a large number of enemies and
only ground tiles
this is the opposite so this is only sky
tiles and no enemies
and this is somewhere in between so this
has both sky tiles and the different
somewhere in between and these are all
the levels are automatically generated
from a single run of the quality
diversity cmame
searching latent vectors of a trained
generative adversarial network trying to
find an archive of diverse solutions
so we saw how we can increase a little
bit the complexity of the content that
we generate i wanted to come back to the
first part which is can we make
can we further improve the efficiency of
searching for diverse solutions
and so all the algorithms that i have
described so far assume that you do not
make any assumptions about the objective
or measures so they treat them as black
boxes
but there are many applications where
you can actually have exact gradient
information of both the objective and
measures
and so this is a differentiable quality
diversity problem that we proposed where
the objective and measures are first
order differentiable
an example application of that is a
style gun and clip pipeline
so style gun will generate an image and
then you can pass the you can pass a
text prompt that says elon mask with a
shortcut and then you pass the two on a
clip which is a model trained by open ai
and that will give you a similarity
score
now the whole pipeline here is
end-to-end differentiable so what you
can do is you can actually do gradient
ascent to minimize the similarity to
maximize the similarity score minimize
the the score output of the clip to get
an image that looks like elon musk as
much as possible
but what if we want to have diverse
range of images so we want to have faces
that look like elon musk with blue eyes
or with a different hair color
now what we could do is we could pass a
prompt that says
a man with blue eyes
and then the similarity score with that
prompt would be the measure of diversity
and so instead of trying to maximize or
minimize that trying to find solutions
for an entire range of similarity scores
solutions where the eye color is
blue but also the eye color is as far
away from blue as possible
this would be a measure of diversity and
now the measure itself is also into and
differentiable right because we use
exactly the same pipeline
and this is a differentiable quality
diversity problem and this was actually
has been an open problem for several
years and we have solved that problem
and we actually presented that as an
oral presentation at eurips this year
and so in the next slides i would like
to give you the intuition on how you
solve that problem
so in map elites the way map elites
works is that we take a solution and
then we perturb that solution with some
isotropic gaussian
can we leverage gradient information in
map elites
well let's see if we have just one
objective and we take the gradient of
that objective then we move in one
direction the direction of steepest
ascent right
but the quality diversity we have one
objective that we want to have the
gradient
but we also have measures so we have one
objective that we want to maximize the
quality f but we also have measures that
form a measure space that we want to
explore
and so how can we leverage gradient
information to explore the measure space
well let's say assume that we have two
measures that form a two-dimensional
coordinate system
the gradient of m1 with respect to theta
is the direction of steepest ascent
of m1 and the gradient of m2 with
respect to theta measure two is the
direction of cps ascent with respect to
m2 and the negative gradients are the
directions of steepest descent
and so we see that these gradients form
a coordinate system and then if we find
some coefficients and multiply the
gradients with these coefficients we can
perform some motion in that coordinate
system
and so if we have one objective that we
want to maximize we can do gradient
ascend here we have gradients and we
want to explore the measure space so
this implies some branching tree
structure
but there is still a directionality in
the search in that we still want to
maximize quality so there is still an
objective f that we want to maximize and
so we borrow the thermal borresense from
graph theory to indicate that this is a
directed research
and so in map elites you would take a
solution and then apply some
perturbation with an isotropic gaussian
here in map elites via gradient
arborescence we can take a function g
that is a linear combination of the
objective
and the measures of diversity that we
want to have
maximizing g results in maximizing the
quality f
and performing some type of motion in
measure space
now what type of motion will be that
that will be specified by the
coefficients
so we could
the coefficients will specify direction
on how we navigate the measure space
but also
they will specify a step size how fast
we move in measure space
how do we pick these coefficients well
one approach would be to just sample
them from some multivariate gaussian but
what will actually work much better is
to use exactly the same insight that we
used in cmame where we said okay let's
search for coefficients that maximize
archive improvement
and let's use cma just to do that so
before we use cmas where we're trying to
find solutions that maximize archive
improvement
here instead of trying to find solutions
we try to find coefficients where
performing a gradient ascent step with
respect to its coefficient
with respect to the sample coefficients
will move in the direction of maximum
archive improvement and therefore will
fill in the archive as much as possible
and so this is a covariance matrix
adaptation map elites via gradient
arborescence algorithm and the idea is
the following
we have a multivariate gaussian retained
by cmas
this is a gaussian of coefficients we
sample coefficients from that gaussian
and then for each sample we perform a
gradient ascent step
from an existing solution point
and then we evaluate the solution that
results from the gradient ascend step
and we evaluate it based on how much it
improves the archive
and therefore then we pick the best
direction that maximizes archive
improvement
we also use the same evaluation to rank
and select and rank the best
coefficients and then we update that
the mean and covariance metrics of the
multivariate gaussian
so to give you an example let's assume
that we are in a 3d
search space so we are the the solutions
here or the scenarios are like in in
this room
and there is one objective and one
measure so you compute the objective and
measure gradients
and this form
a two-dimensional coordinate system so
this form let's say a sheet
and then within that sheet here you
search for the direction that maximizes
archive improvement
and you perform
a step in the best possible direction
and then you recompute the objective and
measure gradients and so now the
optimization landscape has changed a
little bit but we assume it doesn't
change very fast
and then you do the same thing
iteratively
and we can actually show that if you do
that then we
this is the the arbor essence is
projected in measure space
to see how the arborescens work but we
can actually show that if we do that we
were able for the first time to solve
completely some benchmark domains so you
see how the algorithm compares with
respect to like cmaemy and some
state-of-the-art quality diversity
algorithms
we also came back to the original
application
of
[Music]
generating diverse images using the
style gun and clip pipeline
and so
this is a collage of sampled images from
the archive of solutions where as you go
down the hair color becomes um
more and more red as we go to the left
the eye color becomes blue
and but the objective is to look like
elon musk so we see this diverse range
of faces and these are two cherry picked
examples
we can do the same for
jennifer lopez
for beyonce as we go down
she becomes younger as we go left her
hair becomes longer
and this is again a cherry picked
example
and also and this is jennifer lopez so
as we go down she starts frowning as we
go left her hair becomes longer and all
these phases are generated with a single
run of cma mega exploring the latent
space of the style gun
now all these algorithms that i have
discussed we have open sourced them in a
library named pyrips so if you are
interested in try them out please by all
means we also have a set of tutorials so
we can also one of the tutorials is use
quality diversity strategies to make a
lunar lander land like a space shuttle
because we come from the space shuttle
era and so
i would encourage you to
play with some of the tutorials that we
have
so one one um
research direction that i have been very
excited from the beginning of my
graduate studies has been how to learn
human preferences
and so when people provide
um even even in tasks in collaborative
tasks where there is an infinite number
of different ways to complete the task
we can actually cluster we can explore
similarities between users and cluster
them into groups based on their
preference and so cluster them into
dominant types with unsupervised
learning so that when a new user comes
they can very very quickly adapt to the
new type or preference
but what we have been very recently
saw in a more complex task so in this
idea assembly task is that
uh
people's preferences exist in multiple
resolutions so people have preferences
for example on whether to start with
assembling the shelves or the boards but
also lower level preferences on how to
connect cells to boards so exploiting
this kind of structure has helped them
making much more efficient prediction
and we now have been working with a
mobile robot manipulator and extending
this to a much much more complex model
airplane assembly task and we try to
enable a robot predict the next human
action based on their preference and
assist the human for this assembly task
and so we have this is a project funded
by nri
and we have got a bunch of model
airplane model rc airplanes
and students only use these airplanes
for experiments and never fly them
around for fun wink wink
and when we're having human
demonstrations many of these
demonstrations are suboptimal and so
the question then becomes how we can
extract useful information from the
suboptimal demonstrations and so that's
a project that we have also been working
on
i wanted to as we go towards the end of
the talk to come back to the share
comping project so this is something
that we have been building and iterating
on and so when things were still back to
normal we had a live demonstration at
nurips where nathan
has short hair so the robot quickly
adapts to his
hairstyle but but
eura has a much longer hair and
therefore the robot will need to take a
very different
a much longer path and this is also a
system that we are currently working on
and
trying to make it more robust
so when it comes to hair combing
like robust human robot interaction is
important because if something goes
wrong then it will hurt a little bit
but in this operation here this this is
a roof bolting operation inside the mine
where the idea is that you use a roof
boulder to drill a hole in the ceiling
of the mine and then put a steel bolt to
reinforce the ceiling and the roof
bolter here runs on hydraulics so if
something goes wrong it typically
results in very very severe
accidents right severe injuries so this
is actually a very safety critical
application and one thing that we have
been working on in collaboration with
the mining engineering department at the
university of kentucky has been how we
can remove the human from a danger zone
and enable more robust interactions by
having the human provide some high level
goals while the robot while an
industrial manipulator coordinates with
a roof boulder uh
in in in this kind of a
ceiling reinforcement application
so since i started at usc we also
introduced a robotics class so we have
the five
keynote arms and we have all the
students
split into groups and actually apply the
whole manipulation and planning pipeline
on this kind of arms
and so last year we did everything in
simulation but this year for the first
time we had we were able to do this labs
in person which was a
quite
rewarding this is a more important slide
so this is all the students that did the
work so matt fontaine has been working
on
quality diversity optimization scenario
generation for human robot interaction
and latent space illumination
sophisto yulun zhang and brian chanaka
have been working on environment
generation that results in diverse
coordination behaviors brand chanaka has
also been leading the
pirates library the open source library
here up nemlekar on learning human
preferences in assembly tasks annie
roots for running on learning preference
from suboptimal demonstrations
nathan dendler on the share combing task
and hey gil sang on the roof pulling
desk and i'm very very grateful to all
the all my collaborators
and so the the main takeaway that i
would like you to have from this talk is
that there are many applications that
and one of them is robust human robot
interaction and scenario generation
where we want to have a diverse range of
high quality solutions and so in this
talk
we discussed how we can use quality
diversity algorithms
to search for a diverse range of
scenarios that are high quality but also
how integrating these quality diversity
algorithms with generative models
trend with human authored examples can
result in
content that is not only complex but
also realistic
and with that i would be happy to take
any questions
[Applause]
any questions
uh i have a question on the slide you
have uh with cma mega and cmi me
i think the mega variation fills the
archive really really quickly compared
to everything else right
can you give uh some insights as to why
it's able to fill the archives so
quickly
yeah so the idea here is that cma me and
all the quality diversity algorithms so
far have not made any assumptions about
the gradient information so they are all
gradient-free algorithms and so the way
they work is they try
so cma and we for example try to
estimate the gradient by generating new
solutions and evaluating the solutions
of how much
they improve the archive and then
iteratively moving in the direction of
grading with respect to the quality
diversity objective
map elites does that by taking existing
solutions and then applying some
isotropic perturbation which assumes
that every direction is equally likely
this is because map elites itself was
designed to run for a long period of
time so they
it is designed not to have any bias in
any direction
and map elites line is a variant of map
elites the other baseline that has some
that has a different operator so instead
of applying an isotropic gaussian
as noise it explodes some local
correlations to
move in in a given direction
cma mega what it does is it assumes and
it it leverages exact gradient
information so we analytically so this
was like a sphere domain which is a a
benchmark domain where we analytically
compute the gradients
and these gradients specify a space in
objective and measure space that we can
then navigate
and then the question becomes how do you
navigate that space and then we use cmas
but then we use cmas
on the coefficients another way to think
of that is that we essentially reduce
reduce the search from a high
dimensional space of parameters to a
much lower dimensional space of
coefficients where we directly use this
cos efficience and this kind of measure
and objective gradients to navigate the
space
any other questions
yeah so following that question um
do you have any intuition about
how
it sort of balances the coefficients on
the objective cost f versus the measures
so like
is it basically choosing a strategy
where it first exploits an f and then
explores an m or maybe vice versa right
that's a great question right so how do
you pick these coefficients
and the answer is we let cma yes decide
that and so that what happens is that
cmas covariance matrix adaptation
evolution strategy samples different
coefficients where different coefficient
vectors right there where it's
it's element of the vector like the
first element corresponds to the
objective the next correspond to the
measures right so it samples some of
them and then it performs a gradient
ascend step
and evaluates how the resulting solution
how much the resulting solution improves
the archive
and then
it assigns some weights based on this
evaluation so it ranks this resulting
solutions and then based on these
rankings it adapts the weights and moves
them in and
of the distribution right and the
covariance matrix and does this
iteratively
and therefore
because it uses this ranking and because
it has some very very nice step size
adaptation properties which are
analogous to the
to to
a momentum in stochastic gradient ascent
right
it is able to find out exactly how it
needs to navigate the objective and
measure space to maximize archive
improvement so it changes the
coefficients in a direction of filling
the archive
remember i'm more asking like
intuitively like if you were to plot
uh c naught
over
iterations i see do you see any of the
uh say like is it depending on your
problem right yeah it's probably
dependent because and it also depends on
the scale of the objective and measures
one other thing that i didn't mention
that's more in implementation detail is
that we normalize all these measure and
objective gradients
and so that they are all on the same
scale but then how fast you should move
in each direction depends on
whether how much
the speed in each direction
helps fill in the archive but it's
problem dependent right and cma yes well
we'll we'll let cmas uh
find the right scale of these
coefficients and also the sign
more questions also if you are on zoom
you can also unmute yourself and ask a
question if you like
okay so if there are no further
questions then thank you again stefano
for your great talk
and uh yeah i see you next week then
thank you
you